200 mètres de long 400 tonnes six
voitures propulsées par deux motrices
d'une puissance totale est phénoménal de
huit mille chevaux
voilà par les chiffres ce qu'est le tgv
août 1978 le tout premier tgv français
surnommé patrick vient à peine de sortir
de l' usine de belfort est aujourd'hui
la rame numéro l'une prend sa retraite
après quarante et un ans sur les rails
[Applaudissements]
mais au fait pourquoi le surnom patrick
car c'est le prénom du fils du tout
premier conducteur du tgv
un tgv de couleur orange qui devait
notamment rallié paris à lyon dès 1981
une révolution dans le monde ferroviaire
il apportera un gain de temps énorme par
rapport au train actuel puisque pour
aller à lyon par exemple pour notre
afrique deux heures au lieu de presque 4
heures maintenant plus rapide jusqu'à
380 km heure et aussi plus fiable et
plus confortable que les autres trains
le tgv se veut être un mode de transport
moderne en septembre 1981 après trois
ans décès il est inauguré par le
président de la république françois
mitterrand
attention d'une grande force d'une
grande chose de belles réalisations
d'un coup d'audace réussi avec beaucoup
de patience à travers les années et de
réussite à tous les corps de métiers qui
y ont participé
parmi ces métiers celui de conducteur
pour conduire ce bijou ferroviaire des
critères sont requis avoir moins de 45
ans et participé à une formation
spéciale d'un an car d'un côté passager
l'enthousiasmé aussi et là c'est même
devenu une alternative à un autre mode
de transport
l'avion s'est alors comment ça se passe
quand on dans l'avion il faut arriver à
l'aube hier trois quarts d'heure avant
etc il faut aller à orly il faut revenir
de satolas
alors que là on arrive en plein centre
de lyon c'est beaucoup plus pratique
aujourd'hui patrick le tgv 01 prend sa
retraite après quarante et un ans de
bons et loyaux services
depuis sa mise en service il a parcouru
près de 13 5 millions de kilomètres soit
335 fois le tour de la terre
[Musique]